meet Jack Wade Dennis Quaid and Meg
Ryan's 23 year old son he's also one of
the stars of HBO's newest drama final
it's all about sex drugs and rock and
roll and it's co-creators include Mick
Jagger and Martin Scorsese
oh it's nuts right it's crazy I feel
like it's the new craze and everyone is
addicted to I hope so that's very nice
if they are your parents worried at all
ya know maybe for my safety I don't know
they don't know where I am right now I'm
lost I'm very lost
no they're they're there they've been
nothing but supportive of the whole deal
have they seen the show it's risky very
risky oh you meant like with the with
the drugs and the sex and the rock and
roll no I mean they they love Scorsese
things I think that you know that it
wouldn't be vinyl without all that stuff
and my mom's seen the pilot you see the
second episode both both of them have
seen all the episodes so far and they're
big fans which is great no no not yet
not yet
auditioning for Mick Jagger and Martin
Scorsese Mick was not in the room Martin
Scorsese was which was nuts for me it
was that like the Beverly Hills Hotel a
little villa off to the side so I didn't
have to go through a lobby or anything
it was just like coursezi
but I was so nervous but he immediately
put me at ease he's such a great affable
guy really funny what can you tease
about this season anything that you're
excited for for viewers to see the last
scene of the entire show might have been
one of the most insane days of my life
it changed in a lot of ways that is that
can't wait people to see that same